what I've done is hideous
in our communities Sam left prison last
summer
behind closed doors you're gonna be our
kind of eyes and ears on the ground all
around the UK they're the most monstrous
size and most stigmatized of the group
sex offenders are being treated one of
my crimes was against children supported
I will always see someone as a human
being first and held accountable no
one's making excuses for what you've
done
Sky News has been given unprecedented
access to the work of circles it's about
preventing where offending in the future
a charity network of volunteers I want
to do something meaningful helping sex
offenders because I am still dangerous I
have to manage myself with one ultimate
aim no more victims I'm supporting it
and I was raped
[Music]
build you had a pad if you got a pad in
an undisclosed location in the southwest
how are we all
a circle is setting up for the night
surviving a group of volunteers who meet
weekly with a sex offender first half a
cup of tea they've been working with for
over six months how come he can't film
him have changed his name and used an
actor to disguise his voice hey Sam nice
to you so as it stands at the moment in
theory you can't be in a room with a
lone female no because my clothes were
against females and I understand that
entirely it makes sense which is why
well I mean we stick to that as well I
don't really yeah yeah it's a bit like
children okay well my clients was
against children we know this mother's
going right I cannot my license states I
cannot unless it's in the course of
everyday lawful life I walking down the
street and a kid runs up to me and says
I've lost my mommy and daddy in which
case it would beat me I'd get thrown out
phone of police and get the policeman
knows he soon as humanly bloody possible
right
the same with females as well Sam served
over 12 years in prison the objective
here is reintegration back into society
you know there's very few of us who
really can thrive without some kind of
social contact and so I my view about
where we go now in the next part of the
circle is about really challenging you
to look at those areas that you've got
of interests think that you feel that
you don't deserve that because of your
offenses sort of so you try and remain
super closed after that what are you
worried about joining social groups
numerous let's get a rejection get over
line myself to open up to the wrong
person scared of other people's
judgements scared of my awful lot of
stuff erm you know scared of myself as
well because I am still dangerous and I
have to
manage myself so is your core member in
the middle on the outside you've got
your volunteers it works as a circle
within a circle police and probation on
the outside if you guys pass on risk
information to us which obviously you
need to do your and we would then pass
it on immediately to volunteers on the
inside with over 600 active across
England and Wales we get a lot of
university students one and say better
their career gauging where the one who
go in the future as well
a lot of people who just want to do good
their journey starts here so sex
offenders are sex offenders need victims
need two days of intensive training
where we meet two very different
volunteers and when I was at university
studying criminology I don't come from
an academic background it wasn't for
that I just wanted to do something that
would help others I want to do it at the
same time how am I going to overcome the
challenges if I hear something that is
unsettling I know that the most
undesirable and what I've done is a very
serious criminal act you don't know how
much you can deal with until you deal
with it often they don't have anyone to
talk to about their offending or their
current sexual thoughts the training
covers everything from safeguarding as
that relationship develops it's really
important to remain at risk aware - how
to talk about sexual matters with a sex
offender or corps member as they're
called what sort of things might have
said done that made you think oh
actually he might be struggling with
some section for just maybe like he was
or lack of it I just behavior care like
he did at the mumbles I don't want to
vary there what makes a good volunteer
would you say it's very powerful to have
somebody involved who's actually just
giving up their time because they
believe in their capacity to change
doing this work it's not about making
justifications or excuses for people or
minimizing what they've done or
minimizing the harm it's about
preventing reoffending in the future Sam
just
well you said a minute ago that you are
still dangerous or you are dangerous
what do you mean by that committed
offenses yeah if a lot of things
happened which means that basically well
I've got to know to myself to make sure
that I don't go down the same paths
again I do not want to commit another
offense what you've learnt to sense the
offenses is talk to people yeah
I'm not disagreeing with that and yes I
would scream for help if any of my
triggers came up but I also want to
manage myself to make sure those sugars
don't come off I've done an awful lot of
damage to people it is this is she's
hard you know right I don't deserve it
never have done so you don't want to get
too happy because you feel like that's a
disservice at the end of the day after
what I've done I don't deserve it I'm
gonna write hell for what I've done
to follow their journey volunteers are
keeping video diaries why and welcome to
my video diary this is my first one my
family name I will see if they did share
some concerns they're like why do I have
to do it
whether I can handle sitting across and
listening to a registered sex offender I
am concerned about em I don't know if I
can do it I've never done it before I
seem to be defending myself and while
I'm doing this bollocks you were cause
every time I say sexual offenders I get
do you know the bemused stunned look or
why why that group that should be locked
up they don't deserve it what about this
what about the victims and no overall
value points
the tongue feels critical because we've
got a lot of core members that are
assessed and waiting for a circle
daizy's a circles coordinator in London
with a probation background good fear
she helps recruit and assess potential
volunteers eight types of core members
or offense types that you wouldn't feel
comfortable working with because
sometimes not everyone has that even
sometimes someone like you did I don't
know anything about it so I can't tell
you that if you're ignorant of something
you won't know what yeah wouldn't this
particular core member has committed
offenses against adult women so not not
against children with either son so we
need to make sure that there's a man in
the circle of a team that's going to be
- well you said that most of the offense
were my foot on the truth for children
maybe the majority would have you commit
an offense against children but in like
they're the most probably socially
excluded because they're the society's
views so yeah that's probably why we
have slightly more of them a small town
in the BC interior before being brought
to the UK by the Quakers circles
originated in Canada in 1994 is this a
community's worst nightmare it doesn't
have to be the first ever sex offender
to take part was Charles Taylor who'd
committed over 20 crimes he died in 2005
without ever reoffending victims II
support and he's someone to trust
circles UK set up in 2008 and it's grown
in 2016-17 163 circles were completed
successfully
just three were discontinued due to
sexual reoffending that's five percent
in 2017 18 180 circles were completed
with nine discontinued 17%
and for the first half of 2018 1987
circles were completed five discontinued
or 4.5% all new offenses were less
serious with some read as a result of
volunteer information circles very much
target their high and very high risk
people in terms of people who commit
sexual offences the vast majority about
90% won't to commit another sexual
offense
professor Belinda winders been
researching circles for the last couple
of years the key she says is to prevent
isolation if funding is going to occur
reoffending occurs more quickly
following leaving prison so so it starts
to slow down the level of reoffending
even with a very high risk i so if
you've stayed offense free for five
years you're highly likely to stay
offense free however high risk you were
to start with actually it's really
important that we look at protecting
people for that first year or so which
is why the circle comes in so handy as a
as a stepping stone for people to try
and get them to engage with society it
was my first session he wants to be
there the fact that he's doing he wants
to make a difference that he wants to
make himself a better person okay I
think that it's Delphic aid they cope
deserves a modicum of you know
commendation for it he doesn't have to
be days of only thing for him as well
we're starting to delve into a bit more
of the life during and after the offense
we haven't spoken about the offense
it still feels too early for that though
we're making progress to wards
I had been a virgin so a lot of control
and power and decision-making was taken
from me
despite the charity sometimes struggling
to recruit some survivors of sexual
abuse are putting themselves forward to
volunteer and wasn't physically harmed
but it's a it's a violent attack but
that's going to stay with you
Rachel was raped when she was in her
late teens she came across the charity a
couple of years ago the focus is on very
much on the perpetrator on the offender
which as a survivor my initial instinct
was to bolt from that and so it's so
everything
they turn away from that but ultimately
circles are helping perpetrators to end
abuse that that can't be wrong they'll
probably be a lot of people out there
who have probably been through what may
have been through what you've been
through
you won't understand how you feel about
this
absolutely all I can all I can say is
that person is still a person and I
think everyone should have a chance to
turn their life around and to redeem
themselves even if a new offenses
against children yeah there's still I
and I have children and I and I'm
thinking of them like when I say this
I'm not you know I'm not saying this
lightly but I'm if you can help someone
to stop that happening to more children
then absolutely why would you not do
that why would you not try to help
someone
if I'm supporting it and I was raped
well King poking someone who hasn't been
raped what can they see against but that
charity in the work that we do I think
being able to talk about your feelings
as much as anything has been the wave
wave or the opener up for you do sense a
different direction and different
purpose in life how do you respond today
it was through prison officer I admitted
other things that happen in my life
about going to too much too young the
abuse is just leave there that stuff
like that which doesn't excuse what I've
done in fact to be quite honest it makes
it worse because I was a victim and I've
made other victims you've damaged people
but that's but that that is not
something that you're necessarily going
to repeat I've said this before I said
I'd never forgive the people that abuse
me right because I can't forgive them
and I won't forget myself and that's
your right and I won't forgive myself
either because then I might become too
comfortable and I might slip into old
habits and it ain't happening
I'd rather go back to prison in her
another human being for each circle a
sex offender must be referred by
probation and show remorse this is
Bill's third so how do you approach a
core member then as a person as a person
I'm more I think I'm much more concerned
with the person now the person now is
not necessarily the person who offended
the who did the offending and I don't I
don't think necessarily those who who
are drawn to it should be labeled just
as do-gooders they think there's
something that's worth stirring in
somebody else and if they can contribute
to that process then that's the payback
oh yeah I don't think I could do it
personally because of the nature of the
offense Beca works with several core
members and while volunteers share a
circles phone they'll never meet with an
offender alone the her boyfriend Ryan
it's taken time to fully comprehend we
have a circus phone so we don't give out
our personal details to a core member oh
good we're not on call immediately and
unless it is an emergency
what would they consider an emergency do
they know if they think that they're
gonna reoffended they're concerned about
the way they're thinking or if they just
seem to be heading in the same direction
as they were before it's kind of like a
alarm bells ringing if that happened
that's probably where it starts feel bit
more uncommon oh yeah again and like
reconsider you yeah like what you're
doing it's just kind of passing it on to
the relevant people get as much
information as possible then pass it on
to the relevant people which is quite
good for us at any time the number of
sex offenders waiting for a circle in
the UK is around 70 to engage with
sexual offenders rather than just
pushing them to the margins of society
Sky News has learned in England and
Scotland the number on the sex offenders
register risen by more than 10 percent
in the last three years in England and
Wales there's been a 29 percent rise in
the number of reported sexual offences
but the number being charged has gone
down in the last year by 6 percent
between 12 and 18 months formal meeting
stop and you'll start meeting the core
member in like different places like
cafes we tackle very very difficult
problems that many people want nothing
to do with circles UK is supported by
the Ministry of Justice among others but
is having a large part of its funding
cut the charity claims that may create
more victims you can't translate
a couple of thousand pounds for an
intervention and compare that to the
lifelong damage that victims and
survivors carry and it doesn't mean we
justify the actions of of people we are
very very aware of the damage that
sexual abused us to the victims and
survivors and we make it very clear to
the people we work with that we don't
compromise on that at least one hour a
week he get to meet he gets to go out
the house and has someone to talk to and
there's many other volunteers so if you
want to and I hope that you know I hope
that kind of makes a difference by me I
know it's not grand I know it's not
life-changing but you know small steps
if I can balance the needs of the core
members the needs of sort of public
protection which I am alright believe
that I am by volunteering I've done good
and I can I can handle and when people
question me about it or disagree with
what I'm doing um I'm proud for sex
offenders disclosure in everyday life is
often one of their biggest challenges if
the I choose are showing you know say
auntie which is most people and it's
understandable then obviously I can't
disclose to that person you never feel
of it it's like a remote personal attack
on you know because again it's
understandable what I've done is hideous
and we all agree it's not you it's not
me now but it was me then that what's
the difference well the difference now
is that I was a warped human being at
unit the day right let's belet's about
right to do what I did and there was no
excuse for why I did write it I've been
reasons don't get me wrong I mean we go
in to learn behavior we could go into
that what I saw in my formative years
but we are not going to because anything
of the day I was have grown at all and I
made my own decisions and at the end of
the day I knew it was wrong
are you doing anyway a circle lasts
between 12 and 18 months Andy and Becca
are now five months in I felt slightly
guilty at the fact that I'm just getting
along with them but I don't know I feel
like I should be feeling kind of not
angry but sometimes need to remind
myself what they have done their
experiences a typical progress can be
slow and frustrating they don't want to
cry the offense not really I'm not my
core member he he skirts it but he
doesn't go into it and anyone I won't
even talk about it he'll talk about what
it was like in prison there have been
times where I've been really tempted to
quit I don't know kind of sometimes it's
got on top of me what would you say to
people who don't believe that someone
such as yourself who has committed such
serious offenses can be rehabilitated
all change okay I'm not saying I'm a
model human being I'm not saying I'm a
model reformed person but I'm not it's
still a process all I can say is I'm
doing my damage to make sure that I
don't hurt anybody ever again and are
you confident at this stage in your
circles that you wouldn't reoffending my
heart hearts I know I will never
reoffending in and one of the reasons
for it is because of this because they
have helped me to see that there is an
alternative life there is an alternative
way of thinking there is an alternative
way of being I will trust any one of
these with my life in fact I pretty much
do because they know everything about me
and people have been killed for what
I've done
back in the community we're not friends
with the core member we can be friendly
and polite but in
no way are we friends it's a fine
balance between assisting and
challenging a sex offender that is why
we call circle circles of support and
accountability charity work that will be
too many a moral dilemma
some people would Kazumi worse than
whoever in some ways have murder people
emotionally helping some of the
country's highest risk sex offenders
we can't keep people in prison and throw
the key away even though many people
would prefer that but with the victim at
their core it's not letting people off
the hook it's not saying that what
happened is okay and public safety their
aim I'm not going to cure the guy but at
least I can prevent hopefully reduce to
this risk of reoffending those resilient
enough to take it on you were helping
prevent further victims just by going to
a meeting once a week for an hour and
just talking may provide one possible
answer to preventing reoffending rooted
in our communities
[Music]
you